ذكرت الشمال سوريا نذهب الان الى هناك
لنستطلع اوضاع النازحين والناجين من
الزلزال هناك ومعنا من هناك مباشره من ريف
حلب الغربي مركز ايواء الجينه تحديدا صهيب
الخلف زميلنا هناك تفضل صهيب
نعم الناس هنا يعيشون اوضاع صعبه حقيقه
واليوم في اليوم الاول من رمضان عندما
ارادوا ان يعيشوا شيئا من الفرح وشيء من
الذكريات الجميله مع الشهر الكريم كانت
هناك كان هناك القصف الذي تعرضت له مدينه
الاتارب المجاوره من قوات النظام السوري
هذه المنطقه هي منطقه متاخمه لمناطق تواجد
قوات النظام السوري وحقيقه قبل قليل حتى
هذه القريه تعرض محيطها لسقوط قذائف
مدفعيه ما خلف حاله من الخوف والرعب هنا
في هذا المركز حتى ان بعض العائلات تركوا
خيامهم واتجهوا الى الاراضي المجاوره
حقيقه في هذا المركز تعيش قرابه 150
عائلات من الذين تضررت بيوتهم او الذين
نجوا من
الاتارب التي تعرضت لاضرار بالغه وقت وقوع
كارثه الزلزال الان سوف ينضم معي هنا ابو
محمد احد السكان في مركز الايواء هذا
ليحدثنا يحدثنا عن اوضاع العائلات هنا في
هذا المركز ابو محمد مرحبا بك يا اهلا
وسهلا بدايه نرحب بكم بقناه الجزيره
والعاملين عليها لنقل
معاناتنا التي نعانيها بهذه الطريقه يعني
هناك نزوح وقصف
وبيوت متصدعه حدثنا عن الظروف صعبه لكن
نريد ان نتعرف على صوره الوضع اكثر والله
بالنسبه للوضع اللي عنا سيء جدا جدا
من ايام النزوح
واجتنا كارثه زلزال تهجرنا من بيوتنا سقطت
بالكامل
باركنا بالخيام
وعنا الاوضاع سيئه جدا جدا لا في صرف صحي
لا في واقي للقيام لا تحمل اللمس الثوب
ولا من البرد حتى من الفيضانات امس خيوط
الطفنه بالفيضانات صارت تقريبا قرابه 20
سم الماء بالارض الخيمه
بالنسبه للمساعدات الانسانيه هل تصلكم بين
الحين والاخر اي مساعدات اول ما جينا اجوا
ناس وزعوا بس لكن صار لنا 15 يوم ما اجانا
حدا نهائيا حتى كانوا يجيبوا خبز للعالم
اللي هم عم يجيبوا
وعنا الاناره يعني
[موسيقى]
بالليل لما الانسان ما في عتمه يعني عتمه
كنت تسكن في مدينه الاتارب لو تحدثنا عن
الوضع هناك خاصه وان تلك المدينه قد تعرضت
لاضرار كبيره وقت الزلزال والله يا استاذ
تعرضنا لاضرار كتير بيوتنا سقطت وراح
شهداء كثير حتى عندي انا راح
وطالع من تحت الزلزال يعني ضلينا اربعه
ايام طالع من الناس وندفن بالجبانه
تضرر يعني 70% من مدينه الاتربيوتا صفت
على الارض ونحنا من اللي عانينا من هالامر
هذا الفرق المهندسين لا تزال تعمل هناك
وهناك يعني يحددون بيوت ليتم هدم هدم هل
هناك بيوت كثيره ستهدم حسب مشاهداتك في
تلك المدينه والله لجنه الهندسيه عم تطلع
البيوت وانا من واحد الناس اعطوني مذكره
اخلاء عندي بيت تضرر كامل وبيت تشقق من
البيت التشقق اعطوني اخلاق ممنوع السكن في
نهائيا لعدم جاهزيته وخوف من
الهزات الافتداديه او من قصف النظام علينا
ينزل علينا كمان نزيد معاناتنا معاناه
يعني جابونا لهون حطونا بالمراكز الايواء
المؤقته لكن ما هي مخدمين نهائيا يعني
عشوائيه بالامس كان الناس يخشون على
انفسهم من
تهدم بيوتهم المتصدعه بسبب الهزات
الارتداديه اليوم نرى عمليات القصف من
جانب قوات النظام السوري هنا في هذا
المركز ما هي احتياجاتكم بالتحديد نحن هون
اولا يعني بدنا اناره ثانيا بدنا صرف صحي
ثالثا عن القيام بده عزل
او يعني شيء يعني نفس النبرك قيمه حر
الصيف وبرد الشتاء والسيول خاصه يعني نحن
نعاني من السيول الكثير يعني من الامطار
وهلا نحن جايين على مطر هلا يعني يمكن
نهارين عم يقولوا في منخفض يعني محتارين
بامرنا وابن الروح
اوضاع صعبه حقيقه يعيشها السكان في مركز
اللواء هذا وفي كل مراكز الايواء تعدد
مراكز الايواء بسبب تعددت مراكز الايواء
بسبب ان المناطق التي تعرضت بعد كارثه
زلزال مكتظه بالسكان وهي مدن متوسعه على
شريط الحدودي بين صهيب للحديث عن رمضان في
الصوره التي تبدو خلفك لانها تتحدث عن كل
شيء لكن هذا هل هل رمضان بهذا الشكل في
بقيه المناطق ولا فقط في هذه المنطقه
نعم حقيقه البلد هنا تعاني من ازمات كثيره
يعني الفتره الحرب الطويله التي عاشها
السكان تركت هشاشه في مختلف قطاعات الحياه
الاسواق في المدن الرئيسيه حقيقه هي عامره
بالماكولات الرمضانيه تم من يريد ان يصنع
بهجت رمضان
والبهجه في الاسواق وفي الماكولات
والمشروبات الرمضانيه المعروفه لكن حسب ما
شاهدناه في اليوم الاول من رمضان فان
الاقبال على هذه الاسواق ضعيف جدا بسبب
ربما حاله الفقر معلوم ان اكثر من 80%
يعيشون هنا تحت خط الفقر وبطبيعه الحال
الاسعار ترتفع بشكل كبير في الايام الاولى
من رمضان ولا سيما في المدن التي التي
تعرضت لنكبات واضرار كبيره
بالخلف من ريف حلب وكان الله في عون
النازحين
والمهجرين من اخواننا السوريين على هذه
الكوارث التي ياتي بعضها فوق بعض